questa cosa Vabbè Vorrà dire che la
rifarò
quello rosso
ripetiamo Dov'è Anita
mi sembra Laggiù si sta nascondendo sta
cercando un nascondiglio
[Musica]
No dobbiamo completare le tasche
sbrighiamoci io vado dal dottore
tu fai l'elettricità Ok dai
Ciao ragazzi sbrighiamoci a fare le
tasche Forse è meglio togliere questo
vetro così mi vedete meglio molto meglio
dobbiamo iniziare subito con le nostre
tasche e sperare che l'impostore non ci
uccida perché non sono io davvero ve lo
giuro non sono io ma sarete voi a
doverlo scoprire guardate il video fino
alla fine per scoprire chi è l'impostore
e non spoilerato niente nei commenti
lasciate un bel mi piace se questo video
raggiunge i 20.000 mi piace ci sarà la
seconda parte di among Us nella vita
reale e Ora sbrighiamoci iniziamo con la
nostra privatas chissà cosa stanno
facendo rosso e nero
Ciao ragazzi Forse non mi sentite
aspettate tolgo questo
vediamo dove siamo
Wow abbiamo già delle tasche da
completare qui questo mi sembra una
tasca abbastanza facile Prova a farla
subito il codice è qui Proviamo 3 3 3 3
3 3 3 e 3 Ok Prima Task fatta andiamo a
fare le altre tasche adesso le altre
tasche da Creed perché io non sono
l'impostore sono create te andiamo
[Musica]
Ragazzi ho trovato una tasca qua sotto
Guardate credo che devo unire i cavi
colorati il giallo con il giallo il
viola con il viola e rosso con il rosso
proviamo e vediamo cosa succede
[Musica]
fatto Sei solo collegati Passiamo al
prossimo rosso col rosso
anche il secondo fatto
ultimo cavo Viola con Viola
fatto Ragazzi ho collegato tutti i fili
ho completato la task Ora cerchiamo
altre tasche da completare andiamo
[Musica]
che cosa stava facendo rosa qua dentro
andiamo a controllare
ha fatto qualcosa lì con quei fili devo
andare a controllare meglio per vedere
se ha fatto bene e usa' sabotato vediamo
che cosa ha fatto qua sotto Secondo me
rosa è sospetta questo sì fa il giallo
blu al blu
Viola
questo Rosa no rosso
è rosso rosso rosso rosso
e quindi
l'amico controllare meglio giallo con
giallo blu con blu rosa con Rosa giallo
e giallo rosa col rosa rosa che cosa
stai facendo lì
cosa Che cosa vuoi perché stai male
omettendo i fili che ho sistemato
i fili e sta solo controllando dai
sabotando No non sto sabotando ho voluto
controllare perché sospettavo che tu
stessi sabotando questi figli e molto
sospetto rosso No non sono io
non sono io l'impostore guarda che
secondo me sei tu l'impostore io sei tu
l'impostore
Ora basta meeting di emergenza no Dimmi
che di emergenza e voterò te come fa ma
è già scappata
e parto rosso vero ascolta me e il rosso
il sorbetto vero Rosa vero
Rosa vero voterò voto rosa rosa
[Musica]
Il voto è finito in parità e nessuno è
stato espulso dalla navicella spaziale
nero chi avrà votato rosa o rosso Mmm
c'è qualcosa qua nel computer proviamo a
fare questa tasca
[Musica]
nell'impostore
Ok fatto ho completato anche questa
tasca Ora cerchiamo altre che cosa stavi
facendo stavo completando la mia tasca
non vedi che ho completato la task
perché pensi che sono io l'impostore
effettivamente sembra proprio completata
questa tasks Quindi sei tu No non sono
io
[Musica]
guardate questa tasca
Che cosa vuol dire cosa devo fare forse
devo vedere i colori c'è qualcosa qua un
liquido blu forse devo mettere il
liquido blu nella un polla blu che vuota
e questo liquido è verde dovrò metterlo
qua nella un po' la verde proviamo
Speriamo che funzioni boccetta verde non
so perché sto bisbigliando non sto
facendo niente di sospetto sto facendo
le tasche da crewmake bolla gialla con
liquido verde
prima un po' la fatta seconda ampolla
liquido blu
nell'ampolla blu
premiamo ora il pulsante Task completata
cosa Staranno facendo ora rosso e nero
[Musica]
troppo lento
troppo veloce
troppo lento nuovamente
troppo veloce Questa è la tasca più
fastidiosa di tutte finora
[Musica]
questa tasca l'ho già fatta
ma qualcuno ha toccato il quadro
elettrico qui quindi
sembra che qualcuno qui abbia sabotato
qualcosa
o no
cosa devo fare
bene Ho finito quasi tutte
o no il reattore vado a vedere che cosa
sta facendo rosa
è rosso rosa rosa rosa rosa
Sei stato tu a mano mettere un reattore
No io non ho manomesso nessuno gli
attore perché sei qua ho sentito
l'allarme sono venuto qui da vedere che
cosa stavi facendo Non sapevo che cosa
fare devo sbrigarmi devo andare a
salvare il reattore Dove vai a salvare
L'amore
lo sapevano sapevo che era rosso era
impostore Spero solo che nero sia al
sicuro da rosso ora dobbiamo salvare il
reattore Dov'è Eccolo
ce l'abbiamo fatta abbiamo salvato il
reattore
è riuscito a salvare il reattore bene
nero ma perché mi stai guardando così ma
tu non hai delle tasche da finire da
completare in effetti non ti ho visto
per tutto il giorno che cosa stavi
facendo
ma non mi dire che
[Musica]
amore
o non nero nero sarà in pericolo perché
l'ho lasciato solo col rosso andiamo
nero
[Musica]
Chi sarà l'impostore questa volta
nemmeno io e tu sbrighiamoci dobbiamo
completare le tasche prima che
l'impostore ci elimini o faccia un
sabotaggio al reattore la nostra
missione sarà Completare tutte le tasche
e scoprire chi è l'impostore quindi
iniziamo a dividerci tu vai in
caffetteria io resto qua in elettrica e
cerco le tasche qua che Task vuoi fare
tu Celeste tu vai a controllare la
navigazione presto sbrighiamo andiamo
Ora cerchiamo le tasche da completare
qua Provate a indovinare chi è
l'impostore prima della fine del video
l'unica regola di questo gioco non
dovete spoilerare nei commenti Chi è
l'impostore lo scorso video di among Us
nella vita reale ha superato i 20.000 mi
piace come promesso Ecco la seconda
parte se anche questo video supera i
20.000 mi piace ci sarà anche una terza
parte quindi caricù Mates
Guardate tutti vediamo se c'è qualche
tasca da fare qua in Electric venite
Ragazzi ho trovato una tasca qua mi sono
dimenticata di chiedermi mi piace il mio
nuovo cappellino il fiore Guardate
vediamo Che cos'è
Oh no è la solita Task in cui bisogna
fare il suo hype della card e la task
che odio più di tutti
lo avete visto anche voi passato
un'altra persona un altro crew make
terra rosso forse è entrato dopo è molto
sospetto proviamo a seguirlo
è sceso al piano di sotto cosa starà
facendo secondo me è l'impostore
molto strano non c'è nessuno qua al
piano di sotto il che vuol dire che
probabilmente ha usato uno dei vent ed è
sparito quindi rosso è sicuramente
l'impostore Ora faccio questa Task e poi
vado a premere il bottone per le
Emergency meeting così posso riportarlo
Ehi Celeste Che ci fai qua
bene Penso di aver completato questa
tasca era un po' strana cioè togliere le
foglie dalla navicella spaziale
anche Celeste sta venendo con me Brava
Celeste andiamo vediamo se c'è qualcuno
qua
poi non c'è nessuno rosso e giallo sono
spariti non li ho proprio visti dove eri
finito Celeste per un momento è sparito
anche Celeste ma ora è tornato Chi è il
sospetto Secondo voi
rosso rosso è stato eliminato Ma da chi
è stato eliminato Celeste No no no
Celeste no Celeste no
Guarda su uno no no no Celeste no
Celeste questo questo era un nostro
Cream Mate non si mangia Non si mangia
Celeste non si mangia è un crew make
aiuto Celeste ha preso un pezzo di rosso
Celeste Questo è un pezzo di rosso non
si mangia cosa è successo qui gente sta
mangiando un pezzo di Rocco celeste è
eliminato rosso Oh non è stato lui non
so chi è stato ma di sicuro ora lo stai
rosicchiando oh no fermo Celeste
no Celeste lascialo questo
[Applauso]
da bravo Celeste Dammi rosso
[Musica]
è un nostro compagno dammelo dammelo
povero rosso è stato sgranocchiato da
Celeste Ma allora sei tu l'impostore dì
la verità sei tu l'impostore Celeste
devo subito riportare il corpo
siete per forza Stati o tu giallo o
Celeste No Secondo me sei stata proprio
tu che l'hai prima eliminato e poi
riportato No io hai provato Come posso
averlo eliminato io l'ho trovato Non ci
credo che cosa ne pensi
pensi che sia stato io Celeste Sei stato
tu cosa hai da dire in tua difesa
siete entrambi molto molto sospetti No
no voi due siete entrambi molto sospetti
io voto te perché sei sospetta e io voto
Celeste Perché Celeste ha cercato di
mangiare rosso io voto Rosa io voto
Celeste
Ciao Ragazzi sto cercando qualche festa
vediamo se c'è qualcosa qui nei paraggi
venite Ecco ho trovato una Task vediamo
sembra ci siano vari numeri chissà che
cosa dovrò fare con questi numeri ma
proviamo nove sette sei otto cinque tre
non succede niente Forse questa tasca
non funziona
Ciao Celeste Che cosa stai facendo qua
Stai davvero facendo una tasca o stai
facendo finta
download Electrical sembra che stai
realmente facendo una tasca Bravo No
aspetta perché stai scappando
dove vai
non riesco a capire se Celeste sospetto
oppure no Eppure stava facendo una Task
Beh tranne il fatto che stava
rosicchiando rosso però non posso sapere
se realmente è stato lui ad eliminare
rosso chissà cosa starà facendo giallo
adesso
o no il reattore andiamo subito a
salvarlo andiamo
sbrighiamoci
voi che cosa ci fate qua Celeste e
giallo che cosa ci fate qua stavo per
fermare un attore Eh
no no non mi riconosce la mano se lo
metto così siete molto sospetti tutti e
due sono sicura che Oh tu giallo o
Celeste e l'impostore no guarda io sto
cercando di fermare il reattore vedi
spostati
Grazie sei bravissima Io lo facevo al
contrario penso un po' senti già Allora
vedi di finire qualche Tasco Ok io devo
andare a finire delle tasche in Electric
Tu cerca di fare qualche Task Qui ok
guarda sto già facendo questa qui Ah
scusa stavo premendo il pulsante
sbagliato
4 5 8 Ok ragazzi siamo in Electric ci
Mancano pochissime Task da completare e
avremo vinto noi crew makes Ora
cerchiamo subito
Ciao Rosa
giallo sì Hai per caso sospetti su
qualcuno magari sospetti di rosso oppure
di Celeste Ma che stai dicendo rosso è
stato eliminato Ah sì è stato eliminato
non me ne ero accorto Forse è stato
Celeste Allora hai per caso sospetti su
Celeste Aspetta un momento Ma tu da dove
sei spuntato fuori dal vento qui sotto
dal vento
[Musica]
niente ma di rosso
adesso Sì sono stato io hahaha no sto
anche per vincere allora cosa possiamo
fare magari puoi contare fino a tre
prima di lasciarvi la vittoria
uno
e
bravissimo Celeste hai chiamato il
meeting prima che l'impostore mi
eliminasse l'hai visto anche tu Celeste
e lui le impostore c'hai l'impostatore
Bravissimo mi ha salvato Celeste io voto
subito giallo sono stato io Celeste
Diglielo che hai visto male è Rosa
l'impostore Celeste Tu hai visto tutto
lui stava per eliminarmi Quindi votalo
così avremo vinto la partita Celeste
paota giallo
no Celeste no
[Musica]
rosso Rosa mi hai rubato il cappello
fiore
insalata Questo è il mio nuovo cappello
foglia visto che tu mi hai rubato il
profilo migliore ma in quanti siamo
questa volta c'è anche Celeste e c'era
anche giallo Chi sarà l'impostore questa
volta era giallo Provate a indovinare
chi è l'impostore prima della fine del
video ma mi raccomando l'unica regola è
nessuno spoiler nei commenti non
scrivete nei commenti Chi è l'impostore
vi avevo detto che se lo scorso video
amogas nella vita reale 2 avesse
raggiunto i 20.000 mi piace avremo fatto
una terza parte Ebbene lo scorso video
ha raggiunto i 30.000 mi piace Grazie
grazie anche questo video raggiunge i
30.000 mi piace ci sarà una quarta parte
e magari sarà interattiva in cui dovrete
decidere voi cosa fare e gliene vuoi le
varie caselline quindi spolliciate e ora
non c'è tempo da perdere Iniziamo a fare
le nostre tasche andiamo via vai
bene ora che il rosso se n'è andato
siamo solo noi due io sospetto di giallo
voi di chi sospettate ho intenzione di
seguire il giallo per un po' e vedere
cosa fa vediamo se riusciamo a trovarlo
Spero di sì
una tasca proprio lì andiamo
sembra che qualcuno abbia sabotato
questi fili Magari
l'impostore è stato proprio in questa
stanza Allora
[Musica]
devo ricordarmelo Allora come si faceva
questa tasca blu e Rosa No è giallo
giallo con giallo sì no ma questa è blu
non è giallo Ecco perché allora blu lo
collego con
no blu Baco blu non con giallo
Ecco perché ho preso la scossa Grazie
Merlino sei venuto ad aiutarmi
come dice Celeste con Celeste
Sì sembra funzionare
Bravo Merlino è completato la tasca per
me Grazie Avete visto il giallo da
qualche parte
forse è qua nel reattore
[Musica]
ehm giallo
ho una sorpresa per te
Ebbene sì sono io l'impostore e non mi
resta che eliminare rosso e celeste Anzi
eliminerò solo rosso così rimane solo
Celeste e Vincerò la Challenge Anzi
andiamo subito a cercare rosso secondo
voi dovrei riportare il corpo o starei
troppo sospetto Forse è meglio lasciar
perdere entro in un vento e vado alla
ricerca di rosso
[Musica]
ok
nessuno
impostare
non c'è nessuno bene
Vediamo se c'è qualche Task qui Wow la
tasca delle foglie Sì questa mi piace
tanto neppure semplice
Ok fatto
ma ci sono ancora foglie o sbaglio Com'è
possibile che ci sono ancora tutte le
foglie qui Che strano
Eppure sono sicuro di averla appena
fatto questa tasca
troppo strano Questa cosa Vabbè Vorrà
dire che la rifarò
[Musica]
Ok Questa volta è stata fatta per
davvero
Celeste ha riportato il corpo di giallo
giallo è stato eliminato stato eliminato
E chi è stato Forse è stato Celeste
perché è stato Celeste a trovare giallo
sei stato tu Celeste Sì è vero che è
stato Celeste a riportare giallo però tu
perché stai incolpando Celeste
Secondo me sospetto No secondo me tu sei
sospetta come io allora sei tu sospetto
cosa sono stato io io stavo facendo le
tasche Ah sì e qualità
costruttiva stavo ripulendo il sistema
di areazione da tutte le foglie
Non ci credo tanto però l'ho dovuta
anche rifare perché non stava
funzionando bene forse avevo sbagliato a
farlo la prima volta effettivamente
[Musica]
No non è stato eliminato nessuno tu Hai
votato Celeste Io ho votato te e celeste
a skippato Ah Uffa l'impostore quindi è
ancora tra noi Beh sbrighiamoci facciamo
le tasche Dai sbrigati vai a fare le
tasche io cerco delle tasche qua tu sei
un po' sospetta eh E perché stai
parlando
ma quello che dico sempre
sei sospetta Secondo me Celeste Chi è
sospetto per te dovesse vincereste
sì vai vai vai pure
L'ho scampata ragazzi stavano per
scoprirmi ma per fortuna non mi hanno
scoperto e per fortuna Celeste non ha
visto che sono stata io a eliminare il
giallo ora devo continuare con il mio
piano di eliminare rosso ora entra in
una botola una vent e andiamo subito ad
eliminarlo Secondo voi ce la farò a
vincere questa partita da impostare
andiamo
Ehi sei venuto anche tu a fare delle
tasche
magari non l'ho fatta prima io e devo
controllare che l'hai fatta bene ok
[Musica]
stavo facendo la mia Task lì E questa mi
deve venire ad interrompere
Ma che vuoi perché mi stai sempre
incollata
cosa stai nascondendo là dietro niente
ho visto qualcosa dietro
Basta mi sono scocciata cosa
Aiuto aiuto
vieni qua fermati
no Celeste mi ha visto Sei stato
bravissimo
meeting e vado a riportare Rosa
chiudiamo le porte
ho chiuso Celeste fuori e ho chiuso le
porte ora rimaniamo io il rosso
Vito rosso
è scappato Spero che non sia salito suo
a chiamare l'emergency meeting perché
ora sia rosso che c'è le stesse sanno
che sono l'impostore non lo trovo più Ho
un'idea gli preparerò una trappola
Ciao ragazzi Sono rosso mi sono nascosto
qui in mezzo ai divani così magari
l'impostore non mi vede e non mi trova
ha chiuso le porte e ha bloccato celeste
in un'altra stanza quindi sono rimasto
bloccato qui in questa stanza con lei
Aiuto Ho paura che vi prenda meglio se
rimango nascosto qui in mezzo ai divani
Sento odore di
cibo
Ma cos'è quella cosa sul tavolo
devo andare subito a controllare
[Musica]
biscotti sì biscotti biscotti
Mamma mia che buona
sorpresa
[Applauso]
C'è qualcuno qua
ho sentito un rumore strano
oggi nuovo episodio nella vita reale nel
nascondino
Oggi io sono crew mayta arancione
Oh Rosa Viola
tutte le corna sono uguali a quelli di
Avengers
Infatti con queste corna rappresento
proprio il mio segno zodiacale
industriale Qual è il mio segno
zodiacale oggi ci saranno delle nuove
regole speciali Perché avremo il
telecomando con cui possiamo mettere
pausa
riavvolgere mettere muto chi potrà
utilizzare il telecomando Chi vince i
round potrà utilizzare il telecomando e
abbiamo delle nuovissime Mystery bag con
tante sorprese dentro Chi vince potrà
aprire la Mystery bag anche voi avrete
delle tasche perché anche voi siete i
nostri crew mail e alla fine del video
scoprirete avete vinto o se avete perso
quindi Mettetevi comodi lasciate un bel
mi piace e iniziamo con il primo round
se non mi seguite su Instagram andate a
seguirmi il nome Anita Stories
per vincere la partita i crew makes non
devono farsi trovare devono tornare qua
nella cameretta e cambiare il colore
della lampada freemate nel proprio
colore da crew make se ci riescono senza
essere presi dall'impostare a noi hanno
vinto il turno pesca per primo il nostro
Cream e Merlino Vai Merlino pesca
vediamo un po'
Merlino Merlino
no Hai già pescato
Merlino è crew me no non è contento con
la tua scelta Merlino ha preso no no no
no Merlino ma guardino Guarda No Merlino
ho pescato crew May ti impostore E
questo No no no no questo che doveva
essere cromate Comunque conta il primo
che ha pescato e cioè è Crew Ok pesco io
adesso
pure Merlino scioccato
Sei pronto a nasconderti
non riesco no fammi scappare voglio
scappare voglio scappare bene scegliamo
la nostra arma da impostore
scelgo il martello
stiamo a cercare i crimeiz dove si sarà
nascosto Viola Secondo me qua al
reattore No non c'è nessuno
[Musica]
Allora credo che l'impostore sia fuori è
meglio se trovo un nascondino qui
Ho un'idea è un po' estrema ma
proviamoci
[Musica]
non mi tornerà mai qui sopra
ma non ce la faccio andare più avanti
aiuto Sta arrivando
toglilo
C'è qualcuno qua
ho sentito un rumore strano
c'è nessuno qua
[Musica]
Ma cosa ci fai là sopra e sono nascosta
Non ce la faccio più a scendere ci
arriva
Cioè sei subito così posso crederti
[Musica]
a salire sopra Ma
tanto da qui non riesci a prendervi
allora
[Musica]
[Risate]
ho vinto il primo round ora posso
scegliere la Mystery Peck scelgo la
vista di bag Rosa vediamo cosa c'è
dentro
un mini astuccio Sailor Moon anche se ci
sta tipo solo una matita qua dentro però
è super carino perché Rosa glitterato
vediamo cosa c'è dentro niente
Poi c'è un'altra cosa
Mistery box Questa è di Nightmare Before
Christmas
Questo è uno dei miei film preferiti lo
conoscete scrivete nei commenti se lo
conoscete potrebbe capitarmi Una di
questi personaggi Io spero che mi capiti
Jack vediamo eh
mi è capitata la zucca di Halloween il
mio cappello sapete che io adoro le cose
paurose le cose di Halloween mi piace un
sacco Bellissimo
tra l'altro il tizio il tono con il tuo
colore eh È vero Ti imbarazzone secondo
round
prima Task per voi lasciate un mi piace
entro 3 secondi 3 2 1 tempo scaduto
Siete riusciti a completare la prima
Task Viola mi ha rubato il cappello
corna Allora Uffa io questa volta uh uh
Sì
basta Basta prendermi nascondiamoci
Siccome io ho vinto lo scorso turno
posso utilizzare il telecomando
Quindi voi due più Mates io il pastore
pronti nascondetevi Subito
andiamo andiamo andiamo andiamo
ho avuto un'idea otto nove dieci Wow
Andiamo a scegliere l'arma quale Arma
scegliamo questa volta io ho scelto la
mia arma preferita andiamo a prenderli
cos'era Ragazzi ho in mente un
nascondiglio fantastico Mi nasconderò
dentro a questa cesta e Merlino tu non
devi svelare il mio nascondiglio Ok Cosa
vuoi rubarmi Il nascondiglio Merlino
l'ho trovato prima io e poi tu non ci
entri dentro
Ora proviamo a tornare in cameretta e
Merlino Merlino è un po' preoccupato
[Musica]
[Applauso]
questa cosa è super strana andiamo a
controllare venite venite
ce l'ho fatta con il telecomando
Sì l'ho messa in pausa
arancione ha vinto anche questo Rosa mi
sono dimenticata a Vitale in pausa Play
grazie al telecomando Ho vinto anche
questo round ho preso parte che non ti
sei accorto prima che era nascosto nella
cesta Hahaha
dal reattore scelgo la Mystery bag
argento mi sembra di vedere che c'è un
cappello qua vediamo molto interessante
un altro cappello da vicino ma che bello
amore trecce
Wow ti piace Merlino vediamo come fa
Vitale
è bruttissima
stanno benissimo Mi manca solo la lascio
adesso posso andare a tagliare la
legnaia
Merlino come sempre è
scioccato
terzo re e l'ultimo round wow
wow
sapete che Merlino Ahia Carmela
Merlino vi volevo mangiare le trecce Dai
dai dai che fai Ah ah Merlino No no non
è per te questo Merlino vorrebbe il mio
cappello ma non posso darglielo perché
sennò se lo mangia
nascondiglio e cioè ti ricordi la
casetta vi ricordate voi la casetta Dai
andiamo Ecco qua la casetta Speriamo di
starci tutti e due qua dentro Certo
un po' stretto non rimanere incastrato
Mi raccomando Siamo ben nascosti
Speriamo che non ci veda qua Eh Stavo
aprendo la porta No l'hai presa troppo
forte non mi ha visto non mi ha visto Ah
no Ah ah ah Mi ha presa
e ora prende anche il bidone
ovviamente Merlino ha vinto perché è
bravissimo a giocare a nascondino Ed
eccola Mystery bag giallo per Merlino
cosa c'è per Merlino
[Applauso]
cosa devi mangiare la busta è una
pannocchia con le corde
Merlino
Merlino è felicissimo questo nuovo
giochino pannocchietta da rosicchiare
Guardate Wow oh oh oh
impastare nuovamente
Uno due tre quattro i bastoni
Ciao ragazzi mi nascondo qua in giardino
non mi troverò mai forse ho scelto il
Nerf
Guardate un po' Guardate che c'è là
fuori
c'è qualcuno che si sta nascondendo in
giardino Mmm Sapete Mi è venuta un'idea
oltre al Nerf credo che utilizzerò anche
il binocolo Oh ma da una parte si vedono
dall'altra no andrò al piano di sopra
Infatti potrò vedere dove si nascondono
Sì questa volta l'Inter e sono sicuro
andiamo
qui in terrazzo Vediamo Ah vi vedo
troppo vicino così vediamo dov'è Anita
mi sembra Laggiù si sta nascondendo sta
cercando un nascondiglio
dove sta andando
ora la prendo
[Musica]
Allora visto che lui sta al piano di
sopra o no si è accorta che sono qui sta
andando in camera a cambiare il colore
della lampada andiamo sbrighiamoci
[Musica]
sono arrivato prima io riavvolgi
bile
apriamo l'ultima Mistery bag
blu c'è un cappellino secondo me il
cappello parlante di Harry Potter
vediamo
Non lo so
perché sicuro
Comunque non è una cacchetta questa
questa è il gelato al cioccolato
è vero Oh c'è qualcos'altro qua dentro
Sì wow wow personaggi di Harry Potter
siccome tu l'altra volta hai già aperto
questo e sai come funziona lo regalo a
te sei contenta Grazie ok imbrogliato in
questa Challenge
quiz per voi in quale altro video ho
aperto un personaggio di questi di Harry
Potter e che personaggio mi è capitato
vediamo che risponde correttamente nei
commenti vero che mi capiti Harry o
Ermione o Draco vediamo Apriamo la prima
Casellina e Provate a indovinare il
personaggio prima di aprire il
personaggio visto che ci sono tutti gli
indizi Allora questo devo mettere il
dito sopra verde mi sembra che sia verde
quindi potrebbe essere Secondo me o
Draco o Piton Insomma Serpeverde numero
2 abbiamo un incantesimo scritto
Diffido quindi forse potrebbe davvero
essere Draco Vediamo Ah dovrebbe esserci
la bacchetta
di chi è questa bacchetta
prossimo indizio
abbiamo una pergamena chiusa
prossimo indizio eh Che cos'è questo un
piattino con una tazza non riesco a
capire chi può essere questo personaggio
voi siete riusciti a indovinarlo ora
passiamo alla creatura magica un gufetto
che carino
Merlino
Ah ma non era Serpeverde era corpo nero
Questa è cio Chang con il gufetto e la
pergamena Che carina
Oh no sta guardando qua Forse ha
scoperto la camera Oh no ho scoperto la
camera spara un bello scherzetto Vitale
nel Nascondino di oggi
Guardate
camera da letto
cameretta dove siamo noi ora Ciao
corridoio e soggiorno
[Musica]
tutti i colori qualcosa non è andata
bene Nel trasferimento perchè mi hai
rubato il rosa e tu perché mi hai rubato
il rosso vabbè devo dire che ti sta
molto bene il rosa però
serie B ha grandissima richiesta al
nuovo episodio nascondino a Monga come
funziona per ogni turno dobbiamo pescare
il nostro ruolo da questo calderone
impostore Dovremmo cercare gli altri
Crimes Se invece scendiamo prima X
dovremmo andare a nasconderci il primo
Metz devono tornare qua nella cameretta
nel calderone e rimettere la targhetta
dentro il calderone se riescono a farlo
senza essere scoperti dall’impostare
hanno vinto la partita e anche questo
video raggiunge i 20.000 mi piace ci
sarà anche una terza parte Quindi
spolliciate qua sotto se non mi seguite
ancora su Instagram andate a seguirmi il
nome Anita Stories Se volete Seguitemi
anche su Instagram Oggi siamo rosso rosa
e giallo
ciao inizio a pescare giallo prendi
il diavolo cosa ha preso
giallo ho preso creme
non si mangia Bravo
Ok pesco io adesso
ti interessa tantissimo
Io sono
un po' impossibile di evitare un
clemento quindi vuol dire che io dovrò
trovare Vitale cioè rosa è giallo
1 2 3 4 Merlino andiamo a nasconderci
giallo ha deciso di dormire invece di
andare a nascondersi Vabbè ti nascondo
io allora Dai così almeno sei Nascosta
sia un pochino più nascosta 11 12
Ok Rosa si è allontanato controlliamo le
camere e vediamo dove sta andando a
nascondersi
dove sta andando Dov'è
dietro la porta no ha deciso di cambiare
dove sta scendendo giù presto piccolo
[Musica]
sotto al tavolo con la sedia in testa
non si ferma mai
penso che ci sia messo qua dietro
guardate
qua la testa Ora scegliamo un'arma da
impostore e andiamo a prenderlo sarà
facilissimo vincere con le camere di
sicurezza
giallo Ma tu hai deciso di rimanere a
dormire Ok ci vediamo dopo Ciao ciao
perché mi stai seguendo
[Musica]
Ma che giorno ti ha trovato
questo turno
Bravo scorso benissimo Lì secondo round
Andiamo a pescare i nostri ruoli stanno
ha deciso di fare un po' un riposino
oggi non ha molta voglia di giocare
vuole un po' dormire il giallo perfetto
che cosa ti è uscito
[Musica]
il rosa Vai forse una chance di essere
impostore vediamo
[Applauso]
a nasconderti giallo Ok io inizio a
contare allora Eh sbrigati 1 3 4 5 6 7
Io intanto mi scelgo largo questa la mia
preferita
ti lasciamo riposare tranquillamente lì
e io vado a cercare rosso
Ok ragazzi sono nascosta qua in camera
da letto La cosa ancora più divertente è
che io posso vedere con le camere di
sicurezza dove sta andando l'impostore e
spostarmi o nascondermi in un altro
punto
controlliamo dove sta andando Ah E se
questo video raggiunge i 20.000 mi piace
il prossimo nascondino sarà nuovamente
con le camere di sicurezza Ecco non lo
vedete in corridoio
dove sta andando
sta facendo con le tasche Ma perché
ha premuto le emergenze ma che sta
facendo
Forse si sta avvicinando qua
uno
l'abbiamo scampata Per un pelo Avete
visto era qua in camera ma per fortuna
non ci ha visto nascosti qua dove
sta andando Eccolo il soggiorno
ora che in soggiorno possiamo tornare in
studio e mettere la nostra targhetta nel
calderone così avremo vinto Ma chi sta
facendo
che la tua targhetta grazie E ora salvo
sia me che Merlino
ho messo le nostre targhette nel
calderone abbiamo vinto
è giusto sto cercando dappertutto
dov'eri nascosta io non lo posso dire
cos'è quello
niente niente
Stavo guardando un video su YouTube No
quello mi sembrava il nostro soggiorno
mi stavi spiando No no ero stavo
guardando un video su YouTube Ma se
quello era il nostro soggiorno era una
foto
[Musica]
Beh ora passiamo al prossimo turno terzo
round Peschiamo dal caldo
[Musica]
tto questa volta ora pesca giallo Dai
prendi
giallo ho pescato nuovamente
quindi rimane solo un vero dottore
due tre quattro cinque sette
Ok scegliamo l'arma nel frattempo Mmm
questa volta scelgo questa
Guardate sta andando in corridoio
ma che sta facendo
[Musica]
dove sta andando vuole uscire fuori di
casa
[Musica]
è un reattore Ma pensa davvero che
riuscirà a nascondersi sotto quel mini
tavolino
[Risate]
Ma che fa
Ah ah ah
Ma non è per niente una cosa bella ma
che sta facendo
bene direi che possiamo andare a
prenderlo
prendiamo la nostra arma ma aspetta si
sta spostando
che sta facendo
ma crede davvero di poterti nascondere
lì
ha cambiato idea
o no sta guardando qua Forse ha scoperto
la camera
ho scoperto la camera
[Musica]
che succede
si è bloccato
ha staccato la camera Vediamo le altre
camere se funzionano ancora Sì le altre
camere funzionano quindi ho scoperto
solo quella nel corridoio Oh no ho
scoperto la camera nel corridoio in
elettriche l'ha attaccata applichiamoci
andiamo a cercarlo prima che scopre
anche le altre stacchi anche le altre
Ecco la camera ha staccato la spina
Guardate
la spina riattacchiamola
ora dovrebbe funzionare Rosa
no Rosa mi ha chiuso a chiave mi aveva
fatto una trappola l'ho chiusa l'ho
chiusa l'ho chiusa Ah adesso mettiamo il
bigliettino mettiamo il bigliettino
Dov'è il bigliettino
Ecco il bigliettino bigliettino
bigliettino e lo mettiamo dentro il
calderone ah ah ah
adesso non mi resta che liberare
l'impostore visto che l'ho chiuso in
quella stanza andiamo andiamo andiamo
impostore
Ciao
io ho inserito
il gattino nel frattempo
questa volta
ho vinto io passiamo ora al prossimo
turno e vedrai
quarto e ultimo round vediamo
scrivimi Forse allora un'altra
possibilità di essere impostore vediamo
No no
Dominick quindi
l'impostore e giallo
Mi sa che già l'ho un po' di sonno per
inseguirci quindi forse riusciremo a
vincere come greenways Ok foglio in mano
adesso andiamo a nasconderci via via via
via via via via via via
userò ovviamente le camere di sicurezza
giallo Merlino è distratto e nascondo là
dietro e controllo le camere di
sicurezza Ok sono nascosta qua dietro
alle scale vediamo dove si è nascosto
Rosa Guardate rosa è qua dietro alla
porta in camera da letto
già lo sta andando a cercarlo Vediamo se
lo trova Ecco Guardate non sta cercando
Vediamo se lo trova
bello giallo non l'ha trovato ancora
guardate forse se n'è accorto sei andato
Eccolo l'ho trovato No l'ho trovato Oh
no sta tornando qua mi devo nascondere
Oh no ne ho trovato giallo ho perso
bravissimo giallo ora devi trovare Rosa
giallo ha trovato il mio nascondiglio
che era là dietro Ora vediamo se riesce
a trovare rosa o se Rosa riesci a
riportare il suo nome da crew make Ma
dove stai cercando giallo non è andato
là sopra Dai ti do un indizio in camera
da letto ma non è il momento di dormire
adesso ti manca ancora un cremete da
trovare Ecco sto andando a cercarlo
Ecco è ritornata in tavola
ho trovato
l'impostore giallo ha vinto
Guardate quanto è contento
Sì ho vinto giallo
Speriamo stanno arrivando Hai visto
l'impostore giallo è stato bravissimo a
trovarti dietro alla porta ma tu come
fai a sapere che stavo dietro la porta e
ho sentito il rumore di della porta Io
non ho fatto nessun rumore
Merlino non mi ha trovato nemmeno la
prima volta tu come facevi a saperlo Non
lo so
intanto No Ho indovinato
nel prossimo episodio Indagherò meglio
su queste tue conoscenze
voi lasciate un bel mi piace per un
altro episodio di nascondino a Monga
bravissima
si sono dimenticati di me qua sotto
c'è nessuno Fatemi uscire da qua
benvenuti Signori oggi a grandissima
richiesta nuovi episodi di among Us
nella vita reale anche voi avrete delle
tasche durante questo video Quindi state
bene Attenti alla fine del video
scoprirete se avete vinto anche voi come
funziona ogni turno scopriremo se siamo
impostori E chi vince potrà pescare
dalla Mystery box invece di avere le
Mistery box questa volta abbiamo una
Mystery box in cui dovremo mettere la
mano dentro e pescare un oggetto
misterioso eh Cioè ho sentito qualcosa
di strano ma non posso pescare ancora
chi vince potrà pescare dalla Mystery
box Mettetevi comodi prendete i Popcorn
e iniziamo con il primo round predici
cerchiamo il nostro ruolo
[Applauso]
invece Vitale è arancione e Merlino è
giallo arancione giallo devono scappare
dall'impostare così
cinque sei sette otto meno è arrivato il
momento di scegliere la mia arma questa
perché è troppo divertente da tirare in
testa a vita
Ecco andiamo a cercarlo ho trovato un
nascondiglio perfetto guardate
se è meglio subito un cappello però
riuscito Dove siete
giallo giallo
ho trovato
giallo Ho preso
ora mi resta arancione
ancora
non ci vedo ma cosa sta facendo
C'è qualcosa di strano laggiù Guardate
avete visto
c'è qualcosa laggiù
l'ho trovato hai nascosto laggiù Ti
prendo
Oh no
non c'è nessuno ha lasciato il cappello
Ciao
No
giusto in tempo
mi hai fregata mi hai detto una trappola
arancione ho finito Dove pescare dalla
Mystery box magari pesca Uh c'è qualcosa
che di interessante
Wow
non vedo l'ora di mettervi queste calze
di Hello Kitty Berlino è geloso le
vorrebbe lui le case di Hello Kitty sono
sicura che si saranno benissimo queste
cazzo di Hello Kitty anche Merlino
Merlino giocattolo e vuole Merlino le
calze di Hello Kitty Guarda No
no no non si mangia Merlino secondo
round prima Task per voi Di che colore è
vitale senza andare a rivedere Vediamo
se siete stati attenti scrivetelo nei
commenti Merlino è caldo Hai la lingua
di fuori
pronti per
Schiavone
impostare schermo
[Applauso]
è arrivato il momento per me di
scegliere la mia arma quale scelgo quale
scelgo quale scelgo Sì sceglierò pappa
ho dimenticato Ho cambiato il cappello
vedete il cappello con L'etichetta
adesso così posso dare più veloce
a nascondermi mi nasconderò dentro alla
macchina e mi chiuderò a chiave così
l'impostore non potrà prendermi
Sono in macchina ora mi chiudo a chiave
anche se l'impostore mi trova non potrà
prendermi perché sono chiusa a chiave
vediamo prima se mi trova Ah da qua
posso vedere tutto Guardatela giù ma che
sta facendo
Sta rincorrendo gli uccelli
ancora non mi ha vista qua Ma dov'è
giallo giallo sta scappando sembra che
sia giallo che sta rincorrendo
l'impostore
Guardate Stanno giocando se ne accorgerà
Secondo voi che sono qua dentro alla
macchina se n'è accorto
Mi dispiace per te è chiusa
non puoi prendermi
è meglio che te ne vai ciao ciao ciao
ciao ciao ciao ciao ciao tanto non puoi
prendermi sta provando ad aprire le
porte di dietro ma la macchina è tutta
chiusa non puoi prendermi Ciao ciao Hai
perso impostore che in realtà non ha
ancora aperto perché per perdere Io
dovrei tornare dentro e cambiare il
colore della lampada crew make ma spero
che si allontani così posso uscire dalla
macchina e scappare
Ma no mi dispiace per te ma è tutta
chiusa la macchina fa troppo caldo devo
assolutamente uscire dalla macchina
impostare si è allontanato non riesco a
vederlo Quindi forse è il momento giusto
per uscire Speriamo che non mi stia
tendendo una trappola
via libera andiamo
è stata una passeggiata
Ma che versi fa ho vinto
Sì
C'è mancato poco Ma che versi fai
aeroprava il mostro
sono tornato in arancione
box vediamo che cosa peschi Uh Qua c'è
qualcosa di molto morbido un altro paio
di calze no sembra
enorme che carino Un peluche per fortuna
Merlino è rimasto pure in giardino
perché Merlino vuole sempre
sgranocchiare tutti i peluche e parli in
mille pezzi è bellissimo passiamo ora al
terzo round nuova Task per voi lasciate
un mi piace a questo video entro due
secondi ora
due due sei un po' scaduto Siete
riusciti a lasciarmi mi piace entro e
ora facciamo pescare il giallo Mi
raccomando il giallo senza mangiare
l'etichetta
Fammi vedere
vediamo un po' che cosa ha pescato Oh
dottore
Merlino vuole già mangiarmi la mano lì
trattore
sto assaporando
l'impostore sta dormendo È un po' stanco
l'importante
andiamo a nasconderci senza essere visto
non mi troverà
Ok siamo nascosti qua Speriamo che non
ci trova il Merlino finora non ci ho
visto non appena si allontana possiamo
tornare dentro e cambiare il colore
della lampada così avremo vinto forse no
ho visto Oh no che facciamo Oh forse qua
sopra non riesce a prenderlo non
riuscivo
Merlino ha vinto vediamo cosa pesca dopo
la boxe Ok cosa Scegli
o una cosa puoi scegliere Merli mangiare
tutto vediamo cosa prende che cosa ha
preso ah ah Merlino ha preso un
premietto da sgranocchiare ed è
felicissimo quarto è ultimo round Vai
pesca arancione vediamo
Merlino dobbiamo nasconderci
[Musica]
quale Arma scelgo
ragazzi ho avuto un'idea super pazza per
questo nascondino guardate questa
scatola Non so se riuscite a vederlo ma
è enorme è alta Quasi quanto me mi
nasconderò dentro a questa scatola poi
metterò l'erba finta sopra non penso che
riuscirò mai a trovarmi l'impostore
Vediamo se funziona Ecco qua la scatola
gigante Mi raccomando Merlino non dire
niente all'impostore eh
Merlino non dire all'impostare che sono
qua no Merlino Merlino
Ok ragazzi sono ufficialmente sotto
terra Quindi non penso che l'impostore
riuscirà mai a trovarmi questo è
decisamente il nascondino più strano ed
estremo che abbia mai fatto per fortuna
entrano degli spiragli di luce da sopra
così riuscite a vedermi bene ma per
quanto tempo dovrei restare nascoste qua
Facciamo controllare
ma l'impostore non è ancora uscito a
cercarmi
dietro un vaso nemmeno Ehi c'è nessuno
si sono dimenticati di me qua sotto C'è
qualcosa di strano Qui cos'è
sembra morbido
c'è nessuno Fatemi uscire da qua Uffa
non riesco proprio a trovarla Dove si
sarà nascosta nel frattempo mi sono
seduto su questa cosa strana qui su
questo strano rialzamento del terreno
sembra molto comodo Tra l'altro mi
riposo qui un po' così pesante Non
riesco più ad aprirlo
c'è nessuno Oh no È ora che faccio
[Musica]
non riesco più ad aprire la scatola è
troppo pesante questi sia qualcosa sopra
c'è nessuno
Ecco sotto non se n'è accorta adesso la
prendo Merlino devo chiamare Merlino per
venire a salvarlo Merlino Merlino
vieni a salvarmi Merlino
sento qualcuno forse qualcuno si sta
avvicinando
Ciao Merlino
Allora mi hai trovato
Ah e io scappo puoi scappare così ferma
ferma io ti ho salvato io ho salvato da
quella scatola Grazie per avermi
liberata dal mio nascondiglio anche se
mi hai trovato sono riuscita a scappare
quindi tecnicamente Ho vinto io
e va bene Hai vinto tu questa volta
ho vinto Andiamo a pescare dalla nostra
Mystery box
prego sì un'altra capsula dei personaggi
di Harry Potter vi ricordate gli scherzi
nascondini abbiamo trovato altri due
personaggi vediamo che troviamo qua io
spero sempre di trovare Harry o Hermione
o drago vediamo Provate a indovinare voi
con gli indizi che personaggio è prima
di aprire il personaggio anche Merlino è
molto incuriosito
dai Si mangia primo indizio E cos'è
questo è una lampadina Che cosa vuol
dire io vedo l'immagine del leone quindi
Grifondoro secondo indizio questo devo
bagnarlo per vedere cosa c'è scritto
ecco qua è comparso questo incantesimo e
peacee però non ho idea di che
incantesimo sia Apriamo la bacchetta
vediamo uh
sicuramente Hagrid perché questa è la
torta che Hagrid dà a Harry vi ricordate
vediamo
Wow Abbiamo qua il libro dei mostri
Quindi è sicuramente Magritte vediamo
qua e qua Abbiamo appunto il cagnolino
Wow Che carino Tra l'altro Hagrid è il
personaggio preferito di Vitale
Un abbraccio
[Musica]
[Applauso]
Benvenuti solo oggi il nuovo episodio
nascondino mongas Ma questa volta saremo
con il ruolo delle
oggi useremo i trucchetti da spie per
giocare a nascondino mogas sarà super
divertenti più anche voi avrete delle
tasche quindi Mettetevi comodi prendete
i pop corn iniziamo subito con il primo
rimorchio Peschiamo i nostri ronda al
calderone che ti aprirà Wow che dici tu
ti diamo Oh no è il pastore Sì quindi
celeste è giallo che è Merlino sono più
belli
Oh no poi torna qua iniziamo il turno
ovviamente sono stata io sabotare il
resto perché devo provare il mio primo
trucchetto da spia la prima cosa che
devo trovare sono le airpods di Celeste
dove li avrà messe forse qua nel
cassetto Ecco
ho in mente un trucchetto da spia
infallibile prendiamo una delle airpods
Ecco fatto Ora aspetto che torni Celeste
e poi metterò questa airpod nel suo
cappuccio eccoti qua hai salvato il
reattore bravissimo ma girati un momento
stavo pensando magari cambia colore in
Viola e nel prossimo starai Celeste così
riuscirai a nasconderti meglio al Viola
Secondo me perché è più scuro
effettivamente mi potrei nascondere
meglio con il viola
Wow ora prima di iniziare il conteggio e
andare a nascondervi Ci vuole un
abbraccio Un abbraccio fortissimo Un
abbraccio
quanto dura questo braccio
e niente volevo solo abbracciarti per
augurarti buona fortuna ragazzi
aspetta nel suo cappuccio ora sarò in
grado di localizzarlo ma prima scegliamo
la nostra arma Ah è una prima Task per
voi Scrivi un commento con un Emoji del
colore del tuo personaggio quando giochi
una Monga come mi sta il verde Secondo
voi mi seguite da tanto tempo sapete che
io ho un po' di sfortuna con il verde
scelgo questa prendo il cellulare e
localizzerò le airpod così saprei
esattamente dove nascoste e vincerà
subito
Sono nascosto benissimo non mi troverà
mai qua dentro penso che neanch'io
riuscirò a trovarmi qua dentro aiuto
questa applicazione mi dice se l'irpod è
vicino o lontano dice acqua o fuoco come
il gioco acqua acqua acqua e poi quando
ti stai avvicinando fuoco fuocherello
quindi Saprò benissimo dove lo scorso
Vitale È troppo divertente con questo
trucco da spia vediamo dice che qua
siamo lontano proviamo a camminare
dice che ci stiamo avvicinando Vediamo
se qua
no sta diminuendo il segnale Ah invece
da questa parte il segnale sta
aumentando Guardate
No non c'è nessuno e qualcuno qua
c'è qualcuno No non c'è nessuno qua
forse qua
è giallo tu che ci fai là ho trovato il
giallo
sta qua nel tappetino di erba finta che
lui lo adora un sacco dice che siamo
molto vicini vedete nella barra è
diventato rosso Quindi siamo un
fucherello ma non c'è nessuno Dove può
essersi nascosto
71% sto aumentando Guardate fuoco fuoco
fuoco fuocherello fuoco
fuocone Guardate sembra 90 per cento
Sempre che sia proprio qua dietro 95%
vediamo
[Applauso]
che ho scoperto Io ho scoperto questa
scappa a mettere la targhetta Brunetta
Ah ah ah ah
ho vinto questo Raoul che è troppo da
spia è usato Scusa eh Ti faccio vedere
subito
quando ti ho abbracciato ho messo le
erbozze e ho geolocalizzato le airpods
con il mio cellulare
questo è proprio un trucco da vera spia
professionista Allora passiamo ora al
prossimo no che cosa round abbiamo
cambiato capelli la seconda tasca per
voi è di lasciare un mi piace qua sotto
entro 3 secondi 3 2 1
caduto Siete riusciti a lasciare like
entro 3 secondi questa volta era più
difficile passiamo ora a pescare dal
calderone questa volta pesca giallo per
primo Merlino pesca giallo Merlino lui
Allora pescare dal caldo
ah ah puoi pescare un altro Cioè no no
Ah ah ah ah Ah è vero Può essere un
obiettivo
Ciao ciao a tutti ciao ha deciso di
beccare due ruoli uno è cremet e l'altro
è eight perché se avete visto lo scorso
episodio sapete che Merlino ne ha
sgranocchiato un pezzo di crew makes
Viola
ah ah giallo sei pronto nasconditi no ma
che occhi bellissimi che hai analisi del
sole amore attenzione Io ho già scelto
la mia arma segreta da ninja
ora vieni con me Merlino Vieni con me
giallo vieni
Consigliami
[Musica]
questo come nascondiglio sotto le scale
è un po' rischioso come nascondiglio Ma
che ha chiuso la porta qua
bene l'arma è qui e L'ho scelta adesso
Vi mostro un trucco da spia fenomenale
questo trucco Infatti permette di
sentire attraverso i muri attraverso le
porte e adesso vi faccio vedere come
Guardate venite venite per fare questo
trucchetto mi basta un palloncino e una
tazza non si taglia tac adesso sì li ho
tagliato Ecco qua fatto vedete ho messo
il palloncino qua sopra e adesso andiamo
insieme a spiare i sogni mura e su ogni
porta iniziamo subito a questo muro
non si sente niente di qua proviamo su
quest'altro muro
sì e qua dietro andiamo a prenderla
Qui c'è già giallo Ciao giallo
sei stato preso andiamo a trovare anche
verde
no come hai fatto a trovarci subito Uffa
terzo round Uffa ha vinto Viola
l'impostore secondo round vediamo chi
sarà impostore per questo terzo round
pesca giallo giallo si fa sempre trovare
delle impostore vediamo un po' Oh
Merlino senza mangiarlo Mi raccomando
[Musica]
impastare quindi noi due siamo Crimes
e questo è per me giusto pensiamo subito
un trucco da spia da utilizzare contro
Merlino io ho un'idea sarei un
trucchetto di nascondere la camera di
sicurezza sorpresa dentro a un pupazzo
prepariamo la prima che Merlino insieme
Ora dobbiamo solo scegliere un pupazzo
se questo no questa
prendiamo questa che possiamo nascondere
la camera nel cappuccio dell'unicorno
che genio No niente Io volevo dire che
questo unicorno è molto carino Sì Sì è
molto carino
sprechiamoci Merlino si sta
insospettendo ci sta guardando in modo
molto strano iniziamo l'operazione
unicorno No non devi tagliare mi
distruggere niente
smettiamola amica cappuccio e tutta la
camera
possiamo far passare il filo d'acqua
Ok ragazzi guardate la camera è nascosta
qua Speriamo che non se n'è accorta
gialla vediamo nel cellulare se si vede
Qualcosa sì e sta inquadrando la stanza
Sì ed ecco qua la calma in diretta ok
Noi ora andiamo a nasconderci
dove ci
nascondiamo allora il piano è questo Noi
guardiamo le camere di sicurezza e
aspettiamo che Merlino lasci la stanza
Una volta che lascerà la stanza
entreremo e metteremo la nostra
targhetta da freewmake nel calderone
così avremo vinto il turno ora
telecamere vediamo cosa sta facendo
questo impostore sembra stia dormendo
alla grandissima
dovrebbe venire
a cercarlo per mezzo
è così Guarda forse sei a corto della
camera
Ho trovato la camera
che sta facendo vuole mangiarla che
succede
ha preso la camera si è ricorda della
camera ha preso la camera ora non lo so
Non si vede niente che succede povero
unicorno Oh no giallo ho trovato la
camera dobbiamo oh oh oh oh oh
Guardate il giallo ho trovato la
cameretta ma cercando di sgranocchiare
tutta Ferma ferma e pensavamo di
riuscire a usare
la cuffia contro Berlino ma è troppo
intelligente e Secondo me capisce
davvero quello che diciamo guarda Wow
questo è l'ultimo
Intanto vediamo se vincerà nuovamente
l'impostore o se vinceranno i crew makes
questa volta andiamo a pescare
ultima ora andiamo a pescare i nostri
ruoli Uhm Oh no ma sempre tu sei un
pastore per l'ultimo
robot
sta già dormendo pronto perlino sei
pronto a fare il cubeite bene Voi
iniziate a pensare al vostro
nascondiglio ho in mente un trucco da
spia molto molto interessante non so se
funzionerà Spero di sì Devo trovare una
scusa per prendere l'impronta digitale
di Vitale prima di iniziare con il
quarto round dobbiamo rifare le
targhette
Sì perché siccome Merlino ha distrutto
una delle targhette e devo rifare gli
identifit dei crew makes è per fare gli
Identikit dei Cream Mates devo prendere
la tua impronta digitale Ah ok va bene
Io nel frattempo mi piace ho messo il
vaso il vaso in testa il vaso coi fiori
in testa le vado a mettere un po' al
sole che stai facendo
fossero Girasoli Io ce l'ho e le piante
devono prendere un po' di sole per
crescere no Quindi se stanno in testa
mia almeno Prendere un po' di sole
quindi posso versarti un po' d'acqua in
testa
mi serve il tuo pollice per prendere la
tua impronta digitale
il pollice vero No questo è per tagliare
lo scotch
poi il rossetto per prendere l'impronta
digitale Ecco fatto e ora vai schiaccia
[Musica]
Eh molto bene
Ho tutta quello che mi serve aiuto che
non voglio rimanere col rossetto sul
pollice vai vai vai vai vai questa
impronta digitale mi servirà per
sbloccare il cellulare di Vitale e
perché mi serve sbloccarlo Ho un piano
mmm Devo dire che è molto carino questo
colore devo sprecarmi Eccolo qua Spero
che funzioni vediamo Devo poggiare
l'impronta digitale dalla parte non
appiccicosa qua vediamo
[Musica]
perché il pollice di Vitale così grande
rispetto al pulsante non funziona questa
impronta digitale Uffa quello che volevo
fare sbloccare il telefono e mettere la
sveglia 5 o 10 minuti così una volta che
suona la sveglia Io saprò dove Vitale
funziona Vediamo se riesco a mettere la
sveglia anche senza sbloccarlo Ehi Siri
Metti il timer 5 minuti
Ehi Vitale Ma hai finito di lavarti le
mani
perché come si sprechiamoci Vitale
hai finito di lavarti le mani Dai inizia
a nasconderti Hai dimenticato il
cellulare tieni vai vai vai vai vai
nasconditi
nascondi tra 5 minuti suonerà la sveglia
io Saprò benissimo dove nascosto Vitale
anche se l'impronta digitale non ha
funzionato il piano ha funzionato
scegliamo subito l'arma scelgo questa
non mi resta che aspettare qua per
qualche minuto una volta che suona la
sveglia andare verso il suono della
sveglia
[Musica]
Ho provato a nascondermi Adesso vorrei
in giardino potrebbe essere una buona
idea qui nel reattore Non lo so l'altra
volta ho provato a nascondermi sotto il
tavolino del reattore era troppo piccolo
per me forse mi è venuta un'idea
Beh è giallo l'ho già trovato perché sta
dormendo Guardate già lo sta Merlino Sta
sorridendo con i denti Guardate che
carino Merlino quando sorride che bel
sorriso che vede i dentini
Che c'è
sta suonandolo sentite
anche Merlino se n'è accorto arma
ricaricata Non ci resta che andare a
prendere Vitale andiamo insieme
il cellulare è qua ma non si è vitale
una trappola Oh no andiamo subito a
proteggere il calderone non deve poter
mettere la targhetta dentro devo mettere
la targhetta
targhetta cerchietto targhetta calderone
ho vinto
Come hai fatto a capire il mio piano
perché mi è sembrato strano che abitavi
così all'improvviso il mio cellulare
quindi ho pensato chissà che cosa avrà
fatto magari avrà fatto uno scherzetto
come prima con gli airpods quindi ho
detto Va bene ok Forse è meglio non
fidarsi
Qualcuno ha detto
ho sentito tossire meglio che carico
l'arma
dove ti nascondi
è qui e in questa stanza
no no no no no no no no no non farmi
scoprire
oggi nuovo episodio di nascondino Omegas
ma questa volta sarà un nascondino del
tuo colore come potete vedere io oggi
sono Team Viola Slime
cappuccio come gli altri episodi dovremo
pescare dal calderone il nostro ruolo
che potrebbe essere o crew mayto
impostore c'è anche Merlino poi dovremo
girare la ruota per decidere il colore
in cui andremo a nasconderci perché
Potremmo nasconderci solamente nel
colore che ci capita nella ruota In più
c'è anche un'altra aggiunta questa volta
e cioè Chi vince il turno potrà aprire
una delle quattro Mystery ba perché
questa volta Chi vince vincerà realmente
un premio potrà aprire una busta
misteriosa che contiene un premio
misterioso voi ovviamente lasciate
subito un mi piace e durante questo
video avrete delle tasche anche voi Anzi
iniziamo con la vostra prima Task La
vostra prima tasca e lasciare un mi
piace entro 5 secondi pronti
siete riusciti a completare la tasche in
tempo ma ora iniziamo subito con il
primo turno perché non vedo l'ora di
scoprire che sorpresa ci sono dentro
queste buste Spero che ci sia qualcosa
di mangiare anche per me lo sono per
Berlino iniziamo subito con il primo
round prendi in più possiamo scegliere
tra i nostri capelli proprio come una
mongas Allora vediamo Secondo voi quale
mi sta meglio votate nei commenti
ah ah il vaso di fiori È il mio
preferito
questo Galeone
fa paura ma chiamo Merlino come reagisce
un leone Merlino
barba finta Merlino è un po' scioccato
'sto orecchio
Tu invece che cappello scegli Allora
vediamo posso prendere questo da
principessa
non mi sta bene che sceglierò il mio
preferito è il mio preferito è questo
il vaso di fiori
Non so perché ma Vitale allora quel
cartello diciamo ce l'abbiamo lo adora e
il suo preferito in assoluto Ok tu avrai
quello Allora
ti piace il cappello che ho scelto io
quindi questo è quello che hai Beh sì è
viola come il mio outfit Ok è questo ok
Molto meglio così scelgo questo le
orecchie ora andiamo
Vai giallo tocca a te pesca vediamo
Brava brava
[Applauso]
Come si mangia
Buongiorno Buongiorno
Ok tocca a me adesso
bene Ora devi girare la ruota per vedere
in quale colore dovrei nasconderti
blu blu
bene Allora io vado di là in corridoio e
inizio a contare ora
[Applauso]
notate qualcosa di blu qui
[Musica]
è blu blu e blu non vi vuol dire niente
io mi nascondo qui
per nasconderti nel tuo colore tempo
scaduto Sto arrivando a cercare più
Mates in qualcosa di blu Ah ho
dimenticato di scegliere l'arma Allora
devo tornare in cameretta e scegliere
l'arma Eccoci qua Ehi ma tu non ti sei
nascosto giallo
che c'è vuoi dirmi qualcosa
perché guardi qua guardi fuori stai
guardando fuori ho capito allora giallo
sta guardando fuori quindi vuol dire che
verde si è nascosto fuori in giardino
che già non mi dà sempre molti indizi
comunque che arma scelgo Mmm scelgo
questa mi dispiace giallo ma ti ho
trovato quindi ti ho preso
giallo ha perso questo turno Ma ora
andiamo a prendere verde che sicuramente
può in giardino andiamo ok ragazzi siamo
in giardino vediamo dove si è nascosto
verde deve per forza essersi nascosto in
qualcosa di blu
qua non c'è qua non c'è
[Risate]
lì
l'ho beccato spiaccica
andiamo subito a prenderlo
tutto bene Quindi ora aprirò molto
lentamente la tenda guardate
no
Ehi l'impostore ha vinto
ora posso scegliere la Mystery bag da
aprire Wow scelgo la Mystery bag gialla
vediamo un po' cosa c'è dentro Magari ci
sono i croccantini di giallo nella busta
gialla no non mi sembra vediamo
[Musica]
no no no no no è cioccolato e di
plastica
due palette di trucchi
non si mangia non lo vedi che è di
plastica
un bellissimo questo primo premio Spero
di vincere anche le altre Mystery bag
Spero che ci sia altro cibo nelle
Mistery box non altro cibo questo non è
tipo Ahia ahia
forse amore al prossimo turno senza
mangiarlo
basta Mamma mia
sempre più corto sto diventando
Merlino tu sarai un cinese
Sì tu sarai solo un Age eh Merlino sto
aspettando per mangiare tutto
il bottone stavolta userò Cattivissimo
Sì Cattivissimo quindi questo vuol dire
che tu sarai più bello A Berlino che
sarà un X bene Allora devo solamente
girare la ruota per scoprire il colore
[Musica]
dovranno
rosa ah ah non c'è quasi niente di nuovo
va bene Ok inizia a contare vai pure nel
corridoio io io siete pronti entrambi Ok
allora se siete pronti Io inizio a
contare ora due tre quattro sette 14 18
non so dove nascondermi io rosa rosa
rosa Ho un'idea ho una coperta rosa o
questa coperta rosa però se mi metto
semplicemente Sotto la coperta lui mi
vedrà mi devo nascondermi dentro a
qualcosa E magari mettere sopra la
coperta
Mi è venuta un'idea geniale Guardate Ok
ragazzi proverò a nascondermi qua dentro
e poi metterò la coperta rosa sopra così
il colore sarà Rosa Il problema è che
non so se ci sto qua dentro
probabilmente no Però ci provo lo stesso
sarà molto divertente No è arrivato
giallo e mi vuole rubare mille
nascondiglio
Vai giallo e va bene giallo vai tu qua
dentro Ok ok giallo ha deciso di stare
solo qua a controllare il mio
nascondiglio Ora provo a nascondermi
Spero che che starò qua dentro giallo Mi
raccomando tu non devi dire ad impostare
che sono nascosta qua Ok
sono nascosta abbastanza bene anzi devo
dire che non so perché non si sta molto
bene nascosti qua e rilassante stare qua
nascosti Secondo voi mi troverà qua
Spero di no questa volta credo che
sceglierò il Nerf Ok Merlino Mi dispiace
potevo già preso Quindi hai perso
Qualcuno ha tossito
ho sentito tossire meglio che carico
l'arma
dove ti nascondi
è qui è in questa stanza sembra che
questi rumori provengono da lì Guardate
un po' anche una coperta Rosa lì Vediamo
che cosa succede
sembra non ci sia nascosto nessuno là
dentro Qualcosa mi dice che se magari io
mi siedo qui
[Applauso]
preso
Uffa mi hai trovata
sai perché Perché sono troppo
intelligente No non è vero perché in
realtà è impossibile però
ha vinto all'impastore il verde quindi
che Mystery bag scegli
Allora io prima ho sentito i dollari di
cibo Quindi lascerò scegliere il mio
naso hai sentito odore di cibo da questa
misterbike
perché tu le sai qualcosa Oh abbiamo un
po' di snack qui ma vuoi iniziare andare
adesso
[Musica]
per voi Scrivete nei commenti che colore
scegliete voi Solitamente quando giocate
da mongas scrivetelo giù nei commenti
cosa stiamo il prossimo ruolo Vai
crew makes perché quello che ho mangiato
anche a me
quindi l'impostore è giallo Merlino
giriamo la ruota per scoprire In che
colore dobbiamo nasconderci
verde ascoltiamoci Il Giardino Il
giardino
è tutto verde andiamo subito a
nasconderci andiamo ok Siamo in giardino
è tutto verde potremmo nasconderci dove
vogliamo però ci troverebbe subito
giallo Merlino se ci nascondiamo qua
nell'erba oppure se avete visto
l'episodio precedente sapete che ho
provato a nascondervi sotto all'erba
finta ma mi ha trovato lo stesso quindi
ho avuto un'idea proverò a nascondermi
sopra ad un albero Sì no è un po' strano
Non so neanche se ci riesco ad
arrampicarmi ma ci provo cerchiamo un
albero giusto
E tu dove vuoi nasconderti mi nasconderò
odio tra un cespuglio credo così almeno
non mi trovano Sì uno di questi tipo là
dietro
[Musica]
tutto
Wow
questo è il mio nascondiglio
Viola è stato preso meglio che mi
nascondo qua sotto
o no si sta avvicinando giallo
l'impostore giallo ha vinto Eccolo ho
visto i bag di giallo che sta già Ah ah
ah
ecco perché
Ah
premietto il regalo di Merlino è un
prometto da
sgranocchiare in effetti giallo non è
molto brava a nascondersi da crude ma da
impostare è imbattibile perché con il
suo fiuto ci scopre sempre passiamo ora
all'ultimo giorno
no sì dai proviamo dai ce la faccio pure
io se lo faccio anch'io dall'altra
Peccato mi stanno divertendo un sacco
dai pesca fresco
Quindi io e giallo io e Merlino staremo
più Mates andiamo a girare la ruota
Vediamo che colore ci capita
Uhm Challenge
[Musica]
E allora io sceglierò l'arma la mia
preferita
inizia a contare Uno due tre ah devo
andare ok Ciao a dopo
posso andare
dall'inconderci
sbrighiamoci dobbiamo trovare qualcosa
di Celeste in cui nasconderci te
l'armadio Celeste ed è anche enorme
Quindi penso di starci dentro spero che
l'impostore non mi troverà subito però
Okay vediamo cos'hai dentro l'armadio
presto Vuoi venire con me nascondersi
dentro l'armadio
c'è abbastanza spazio giallo è andato a
nascondersi da qualche altra parte
versione Ninja in arrivo alla ricerca di
Viola e giallo
credo di aver già trovato giallo Qui
Christian
giallo
cosa ci facevi qui e purtroppo per te è
giallo io ho trovato
hai perso ha trovato Merlino forno che
ci fai lì Stai annusando il cibo c'è del
cibo qua dentro
nel frattempo noi andiamo a cercare
viola dove sarà
dietro la scrivania
quindi magari qua dentro
E allora qua dentro
no
magari Viola ha lasciato questa stanza
forse la devo andare a cercare da
un'altra parte ninja verde all'attacco
Ok ragazzi l'impostore è andato a
un'altra stanza sbrighiamoci usciamo
dall'armadio E mettiamo la targhetta
crew make nel calderone Così approfitto
il turno andiamo
via libera
[Musica]
targhetta crew make Anzi prendo anche
quella di Merlino Ecco qua mettiamo
entrambe le targhette nel calderone
ho vinto
non sei riuscita a trovarmi e non ti
dico neanche dove ero nascosta perché oh
oh
che hai in testa niente L'ho appoggiata
qui per Per tenerla comoda e
ora hai visto giallo Abbiamo vinto anche
se tu sei stato trovato sarebbe
impossibile o comunque messo la tua
targhetta Luca calderone abbiamo vinto
vediamo cosa c'è in questa miss bag
Allora abbiamo un Uh uh uh uh un
extension colorate
Che bello Guarda che bei colori la provo
subito come mi stanno in testa
Proviamo adesso Vitale
[Musica]
con l'extension Hahaha Devo dire che
stai benissimo Però è sconvolto da
questa cosa è scioccata Merlino Che ne
pensi Merlino sta bene evitare con le
extension poi abbiamo tre evidenziatori
E no perché sono nero e grigio No questi
sembrano degli evidenziatori ma in
realtà sono per il trucco Sì un eyeliner
mi sa che è tutto storto Buonasera
[Applauso]
poi l'ultima cosa
cos'è Harry Potter è un funko pop
misterioso un personaggino misterioso
dentro questo Globo di vetro andiamo a
vedere chi ci capita Spero che mi capiti
Io Ermione Hermione con il vestito rosa
che bella oppure anche La Fenice ma
anche Silente vediamo Sono tutto
Sentiamo chi è
Oh che bello Luigi
Uh Guardate che carino È difficile
Guardate che bello con la neve dentro
nuovo episodio a Monga questa volta sarà
una caccia al tesoro
come funziona questa caccia al tesoro a
Monga prima che scade il tempo dovremmo
uscire fuori in giardino e recuperare
tutte le armi di
amongas chi recupera per primo tutte le
armi può tornare qua e dovrà cambiare
colore alla lampada Crime con il proprio
colore Se riesci a fare tutto questo
prima che scade il tempo avrai vinto il
turno e potrai aprire una delle Mystery
bag che contengono una sorpresa un
regalo misterioso però se è un altro
create ha una delle armi o più delle
armi e colpisce l'altro create
l'altroclimate deve rimanere
utile per 10 secondi
e infatti questa caccia al tesoro non è
un gioco di squadra ma è una sfida
all'ultima TAC in più durante il video
anche voi avrete delle tasche perché
anche voi siete i nostri crew makes o
magari c'è qualche impostazione
Mettetevi comodi prendete i Popcorn se
questo video raggiunge i 20.000 mi piace
ci sarà un'altra caccia al tesoro e
iniziamo con il primo round
e ovviamente gioca con noi anche la
nostra mascotte Merlino il cagnolino lui
sarà il nostro aiutante pronti inizio
del timer tra 3 2 1 Ah ah ah
corri corri corri corri corri corri
corri corri
dobbiamo subito trovare qualche arma
così se abbiamo almeno un'arma potremmo
colpire Vitale e fermarlo per dirsi i
secondi che sta facendo Che stai facendo
va bene non ho tempo
ho trovato il Nerf
continuiamo a cercare le altre ragioni
presto
bene Ho già due Lascia lascia lascia
lascia lascia
stare
fondo
che cazzo è successo
Ho perso
mi hai lanciato il martello tu hai
un'arma in mezzo io ne ho due e mezzo
ha bloccato e ora prendo questo e prendo
questo Ciao ciao
corriamo 3 2 1 ora
deve rimanere fermo per altri 10 secondi
Sì ho recuperato tutte le armi e quelle
che non avevo le rubate a Vitale Ora mi
manca solo una cosa da fare devo
cambiare il crew make con il mio colore
Eccolo qua mettiamo il rosso sì
8 9 e 10
ha vinto il Raoul ho vinto il primo
round No l'ho già cambiata il rosso sì
ho conquistato la lampada nel primo
round ho vinto ora posso scegliere la
Mystery bag Ma prima una tasca per voi
lasciate un mi piace entro 4 secondi 4 3
2 1 8 è pu scaduto svegliamo ora la
Mystery bag scelgo questa gialla vediamo
un po' cosa c'è vediamo
Harry Potter qualcosa di Harry Potter
c'è scritto che è una bacchetta
misteriosa potrebbe capitare una
bacchetta di Questi personaggi Wow
vediamo quali io mi capita
che
la bacchetta che mi è capitata è quella
di Victor krum Questa è la bacchetta
e questo è il piedistallo Pensavo fosse
un po' più grande questa bacchetta
è una bacchetta in miniatura ovviamente
alla fine vincerà la Challenge chi
riuscirà a conquistare più Mystery bag
Tu sei già in vantaggio ne hai già preso
una non è giusto siamo uno a zero e alla
fine del video voi Dovreste scrivere
qual è stata la vostra Mystery bag
Preferita ma ora passiamo al secondo
round 3 2 1 1
oh oh oh ho già trovato qualcosa qui
attenzione Ah ah ah il martello malefico
Andiamo andiamo
ultima arma dove sarà oh oh oh oh oh oh
aspetta aspetta aspetta
c'ho tutte le armi qui lo posso
dimostrare oggi sta arrivando di nuovo
aiuto
Non ci posso credere ma è stato
difficilissimo è difficilissimo portare
in giro quattro armi Celeste Celeste
Wow e adesso posso scegliere la mia
vista di Bags Mystery bag scegli Allora
secondo me c'è qualcosa di bello in
questa qui Rosa quindi scelgo questa qui
Rossa Ok Aprila e vediamo
tante cose colorate qua dentro
Ah cosa Ah ah no È bellissimo il
cappello è delicata Adesso prendo il
volo Uh uh uh uh
grazie Lo adoro vediamo Vediamo se
decolla uh uh wow
terzo round abbiamo un nuovo colore da
Green made in Italia sono un nuovo
cappello che adora si è innamorato visto
che con questo cappello È tutto colorato
posso scegliere uno di questi colori per
la lampada Sì giallo il colore del
cappello non cambia il colore del crew
mente ma questo cappello ti piace più
del cappello del vaso coi fiori avete
deciso Ci devo un po' pezzare Anche
questa è molto bello eh pronti per il
terzo round 3 2 1 via uh ah ah ah ah ah
questa non è altro dove sono guardate
come va veloce con quell'elica
ho trovato il martello Eccolo eccolo
posso fermare Vitale
Non ti avvicinare
qua non c'è niente
Sta cercando di colpirmi per rubarmi
l'arma giallo
immobile Ciao E ora che rosa è mobile
posso continuare a cercare le armi
non riesco a trovarle però
non so dove sia
non mi hai neanche rubato l'arma quando
mi hai immobilizzato Peggio per te Ora
ne ho due Hahaha
Ok passati 10 secondi
aiuto aiuto aiuto
immobilizzato Ecco
Vitale ancora immobilizzato Guardate
l'elica con il vento però poco Vitale
prenderà il volo
Oh no ho bisogno di più spinta elica
Forza dai più veloce
volare
[Musica]
giusto Ecco a tutte le armi questa volta
l'elica ti ha dato un po' di spinta ma
non ti aiuta tantissimo
vediamo cosa c'è dentro
Sì un'altra Ho visto Harry Potter che
Harry Potter se avete visto lo scorso
episodio amongas nascondino sapete che
altri Mystery bag abbiamo aperto Anzi la
vostra seconda tasca e rispondere a
questa domanda Quiz Che personaggio mi è
capitato nello scorso video di Harry
Potter
scrivetelo nei commenti vediamo chi
risponde correttamente chi ci sarà in
questa Mystery box oh oh Erry Che carino
Guarda gli occhiali che carini
gli occhiali sono tutti ah ah pantalone
dentro gli occhiali che carina quarto e
ultimo round Chi vincerà l'ultimo round
pronti 3 2 1 1
presto presto
Arrivo arrivo
controlliamo bene sugli alberi
Dove stai andando Oh no Ho già trovato
un'arma e in alto
[Risate]
colpito ora deve rimanere fermo per 10
secondi l'elica non ti è servita in
questo caso potevi semplicemente
azionarlo e volare sopra il ramo Grazie
tempo scaduto
è caduto in testa
[Musica]
non si vede Ma guardate che cosa ho
trovato qui
presa sono riuscito a farla cadere
Sarà una battaglia alla prima arma
No no Non ci provare
[Musica]
Oh Non ci provare
no no no no no
aiuto aiuto aiuto aiuto
Mi dispiace per te evitare penso che
vincerò io questo round
ho tutte le armi Sì bene vado a cambiare
le lampade avrò vinto l'ultima pizza di
bag
Oh no Anita ho trovato tutte le armi Oh
adesso ho perso
non ha trovato tutte le armi se ce n'è
una lì vero eccola qui
vero Merlino Beh se è così allora ho un
piano prima prendiamo un'arma Eccola qua
e ora ultima arma facciamo facciamo
subito
Ah ah ah ah ah
Grazie e avevi dimenticato che erano
quattro le armi Quindi visto che io ho
tutte e quattro le armi adesso no
pulsante giallo
giallo
Indovina chi ha vinto
Sì ho vinto io ho vinto io
L'avevi dimenticata era proprio vicino
alla porta però è dimenticata l'ho presa
Iolanda
Uh uh uh wow che cosa c'è qua dentro
un gomitolo di lana no
che cosa sono questi un giochino per
Merlino
[Musica]
Credo di aver capito è un cappello bello
hahaha
Fermi Berlino
sta vincendo Merlino vestito Berlino
Vitale si è trasformato in un vichingo è
bellissimo questa Barbara Voglio provare
anch'io Berlino è scioccato non lo
riconoscevi tanto
che voto date a Vitale vichingo da 1 a
10 Secondo me sta benissimo con questa
barba enorme
siete pronti a vedere il ninja con la
barba sì Vediamo No Merlino No
cioè Merlino che se ne vuole mangiare
aiuto
come sto malissimo
d'ora in poi chiamatemi a Rito
Anita Stories
Merlino mi riconosci che sono
mi riconosci che sono sempre io Merlino
ultima Task per voi da parte di Anita
Stories
nei commenti è stata la vostra Mystery
bag preferita la mia Sono indecisa tra
il personaggio di Harry Potter anche il
cappello elica era bellissimo Ma anche
questo è bellissimo
scelgo questo perché adoro questa barba
per me invece il cappello di Harry che
rimane il mio preferito browser
[Risate]
[Musica]
Qual è il tuo colore preferito Merlino
Guarda guarda il blu come i tuoi occhi
no non si mangia Merlino il rosso ti
piace
cos'è Merlino che succede vieni Che
cos'è questo allarme sembra provenire
dal corridoio Merlino hai visto qualcosa
[Musica]
Ma chi sei tu che cosa vuoi
per i cavalli
altrimenti salutate
In effetti un po' fastidioso questo
rumore mi sa che vado a controllare Beh
ciao ciao
[Musica]
vabbè andiamo a spegnere questo allarme
fastidioso Ok andiamo
Forse l'impostore aveva ragione o
scappare da lui e non devo essere presa
altrimenti potrebbe eliminarmi Ma dov'è
Dov'è il pulsante per far smettere
questo allarme Eccolo
finalmente Beh ora Speriamo che
l'impostore se ne sia andato via per
sempre qua c'è la mappa e qua c'è una
tasca proviamo a fare questa tasca e
vediamo se succede qualcosa
non è successo niente
è comparso un ingrediente sul tavolino
Ora capisco devo completare l'età per
trovare tutti gli ingredienti torniamo
in studio e vediamo se c'è qualche altra
tasca
Ciao
per fortuna non c'è nessuno in studio
quindi devo trovare tutti gli
ingredienti Slime fare lo Slime senza
che mi prenda l'impostore altrimenti mi
eliminerà e avrò perso la Challenge voi
Mi raccomando lasciate un bel mi piace
se questo video raggiunge i 20.000 mi
piace ci sarà una seconda parte in cui
magari potrei essere io l'impostore cosa
ne pensate se non mi seguite ancora su
Instagram andate a seguirmi il nome
Anita Stories Se volete Seguitemi anche
su Tik Tok il nome è sempre Anita
Stories Ma ora cerchiamo qualche Task da
completare Ho già il bicarbonato Ecco
una tasca facilissima fare il download
di questi file
mi basta Semplicemente
Ok mentre Scarica vediamo se c'è qualche
altra Task Merlino Ma tu da quanto tempo
sei qua non ti avevo visto Hai visto
l'impostore da qualche parte
non l'hai visto E comunque avvisami se
arriva l'impostore ok Non ti alleare con
l'impostore o non diventare impostori
anche tu mi raccomando Grazie per questi
bacini Task completata è apparsa la
ciotola e la spatola 2 in 1 Vai Quindi
abbiamo bicarbonato spatola e ciotola
manca la soluzione per lenti e la colla
Merlino c'è qualche altra Task qua Dimmi
Task della card proviamo questa Ok
Inserisci la carta
Eccola qua
troppo lento troppo veloce
troppo lento Uffa questa è la task più
fastidiosa di tutte
Ah finalmente accettata Ma dov'è
l'ingrediente non vedo niente qua
l'impostore Merlino vieni scappa con me
Vieni vieni con me Merlino
C'è mancato poco che mi prendesse mi
avrebbe eliminato dal gioco Il problema
è che non ho fatto in tempo a prendere
l'ingrediente dopo che ho completato la
task della Kart Spero che non lo rubi
lui adesso Potrebbe benissimo starlo
sabotando lui e ho lasciato anche gli
altri ingredienti in studio può essere
che lui listino sabotando e facendo
sparire magari li ha espulsi e stanno
viaggiando nello spazio meglio che
vediamo vediamo se c'è qualche Task qua
ecco un'altra Task quella dei cavi
elettrici devo collegare i colori dei
fili quindi Viola con Viola giallo con
giallo blu con blu Insomma se avete
visto lo scorso video di among Us nella
vita reale sapete già cosa devo fare
o no ho sbagliato
Era questo ne manca solo uno
Anzi non era questo era questo
completata
non è ancora apparso l'ingrediente Uffa
Ancora tu
Merlino è meglio lasciare l'impostore là
dentro se lo merita
Bye bye un pastore
ho chiuso l'impostore a chiave in camera
ora Speriamo di poter completare
tranquillamente le tasche Guardate Ho
perso qualcosa lì sotto la tasca che ho
completato prima sono apparsi i glitter
Rossi i glitter argento è arrivato anche
Merlino a controllare hai visto Merlino
faremo lo Slime glitterato con i colori
dell'impostore manca solo la colla e la
soluzione per lenti vediamo se c'è
qualche altra tasca qua siamo magari
devo completare questa task
ecco qua
bene
non è comparso niente Uffa non ha
funzionato
aspettate c'è qualcosa qua nella ampolla
rossa
liquido Che cos'è Secondo te Merlino
non è per lenti dopo che ho completato
la tasca e la soluzione per lenti è
apparsa in una delle ampolle quella
rossa come l'impostore Bene manca solo
la colla Il problema è che ho completato
la task dei fili elettrici ma non ho
fatto in tempo a prendere gli
ingredienti ingrediente Quindi sarà lì e
sarà sicuramente la colla Perché è
l'ultimo ingrediente che manca il
problema è che in camera c'è l'impostore
quindi devo per forza tornare in camera
e prendere la colla senza essere presa
altrimenti avrò fallito la missione cioè
la Challenge Ho un'idea prendiamo
qualcosa per difenderci e per
sconfiggere gli impostore Secondo voi
questo Potrebbe bastare per sconfiggerlo
O almeno per tornirlo e distrarlo un po'
in modo da rubare la colla Merlino Tu
che ne pensi Potrebbe bastare Questo per
sconfiggere l'impostore No ma non si
mangia Perché provi a mangiare qualsiasi
cosa a Merlino Merlino Sei bellissimo Ah
ah ah hai gli occhi del colore del cielo
Grazie per questi bacini e perché ho
detto che sei bellissimo ma ci sei
sempre storia bellissimo vero
È arrivato il momento di andare e
affrontare l'impostore una volta per
tutte Ah devo prendere la chiave per
aprire la porta
sì
eccolo qua c'era l'impostore
sulle mani
lascia subito la colla no Merlino perché
stai difendendo l'impostore Sì anche tu
un impostore
spostati
ha subito la colla
Come no se non lasci la colla sarà la
tua fine
Peggio per te io ti avevo avvisato
[Musica]
l'ho presa
scappiamo scappa scappa scappa scappa
[Musica]
ho tutto Ora sbrighiamoci creiamo subito
lo Slime dell'impostore andiamo prima
ingrediente con la trasparente
poi tantissimi glitter Wow Guardate
quanti glitter però Quasi uno Slime
natalizio mettiamo anche glitter
argentati
Wow
mescoliamo Wow quanto brilla
è bellissimo
Wow
soluzione per lenti
per finire bicarbonato Ecco fatto lo
Slime è pronto Guardate che bello è
super glitter rosso
[Musica]
glitterato come le mie unghie vi
piacciono le mie unghie rosa Gold
Oh
no ma non ti avevo sconfitto già
in realtà cosa per niente
Beh mi dispiace per te impostore ma io
ho completato tutte le tasche e quindi
completato la missione creato lo Slime
dell'impostore quindi peccati questo
sì ce l'abbiamo fatta Abbiamo sconfitto
l'impostore lasciate un mi piace per
altre Challenge con l'impostore E ora vi
lascio qua quattro caselline su cui
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
cliccate su quella che preferite e buona
visione Ciao